hi everyone i am umbra suhil welcome to
simply lance youtube channel in this
session we will learn about pyspark data
frame
if you want more amazing tech related
videos do like and subscribe and hit the
bell icon to stay tuned
[Music]
by spark data frame
big data is a skill set that probably
all data scientists have at this moment
that take us to spark one of the most
popular tools for working with big data
spark has recently made a data frame api
available for data scientists to use
replacing its former heavier reliance on
rdd manipulations
so let's quickly look at the today's
video's agenda
i will start this session with the
introduction to pi spark
next we will understand pi spark data
frame
then we will have a look at its features
after that we will learn the use of data
frames
and then i will show you guys how to
create data frame from various sources
and will finish off this video with two
amazing use cases which will help you
understand data frames better
introduction to pi spark
python spy spark provide an interface
for apache spark
it enables you to create spark
application using python apis and gives
you access to the pyspark shell
enabling interactive data analysis in a
distributed setting most of the sparks
functionality including spark sql data
frame streaming mlib and sparkcore are
supported by pi spark
pi spark is a useful language to learn
to build more scalable analysis and
pipelines if you are already familiar
with python and tools like pandas with
this let's move on to our next topic now
that is what is pi spark data frame
our distributed grouping of rows with
name columns is known as data frame
in layman's terms it is equivalent to an
axle sheet with column headers or a
table in a relational database
it has several traits in common with rdd
we can create a data frame or rdd only
once
we cannot modify it after applying
transformation a data frame or rdd can
be transformed
in other words a task is not carried out
until an action is taken
both the rdd and the data frame have a
distributed design
i'm sure you might be wondering why
exactly we need data frames now let's
discuss that
data frames features
distributed
lazy evolution immutable
coming to distributed
data frames are distributed data
collection data arranged into rows and
columns in pi spark
a data frame has the name and the type
for each column
data frames are comparable to
conventional database tables in that
they are organized and brief
the next feature is lazy evolution
although scala may be executed lazily
and spark is written in scala
spark's default execution mode is lazy
this means that up until the action is
invoked no operation over an rdt
data frame or data set are ever computed
next is immutable
immutable storage includes data frame
data sets and rdds that is resilient
distributed data sets
the word immutability means inability to
change
when used in difference to an object it
signifies that its state cannot be
changed once it is formed
compared to python these data frames are
immutable and provide less flexibility
when manipulating rows and columns
so let's go ahead and create some data
frames
let's start the demo i will demonstrate
how to create a data frame in pi spark
by using google collab rather than price
pack shell because i find it easier to
work with so guys let's go ahead and
start the demo
firstly we need to have spark configured
on our device to use the pi function
for this you need to open your command
prompt
and then type in this command to install
pi spark that is pip
install
nice pack
after installation
so now
here we are ready to get started
we can create our data frame
now firstly we will have to set up pi
spark
for that we have to use the command
let's see
installing
pi spark
let's get to the
code pip install
by spark
by spark
let's execute the command
we have to wait for a minute i guess
it will take some time
let it install
now as you can see that pi spark is
setting up
so
let's wait
it's all set up now we can move on to
creating an example data frame for
department
and student
so the first step is to import the pi
spark sql
from pi spark
sql dot import
from pi spark
dot
sql
import
so now
we should execute this
after the import is successful i'm going
to create a student database using the
row function
so we will write
create
a tab
sorry create a table for students
now we will go to code
and write
students
equal
row
and
then we will write the elements inside
the row
okay as
so we will write inside
first name
and last name
now email
age
roll number
now in student we have columns
named as first name last name email age
and roll number
so now we will create data for some
students
we will write student 1 equals
then
inside the brackets we will write
student
inside the bracket we will write
john
here we will write john
that is the first name then the mrl
which is the last name
then we will write the email
john at the rate of simply
dot n
and then we will write the h
that is 21
and then we will write the real number
that is one five four two three
let's execute it
again we will do the same for the rest
of them like we will just copy this one
then paste then we will change the
specific first name last name email id
etc
let's put in 2
3
that is 4
5.
we have to change the first name of
every serial number
second name is cassie
there is no specific last name i guess
so
we have to write none
email address of cassie
that is cassie
at the rate of simply dot n
and the 8
22
and the roll number
1 4 5 2
six
so we have to do the same for the rest
of them you just have to change the
first name
last name email
age and roll number
let's come to student
3 that is
lois with the first name lopez with the
last name and email is lois at the name
of simply
dot n
and the age is 19
roll number
that is
one two three four three
coming to student
fourth
that is
jack
with the
surname
doris
so jack torres has his email as
jack
sorry
that has its email none
the age is 23 and the rule number is
1 3
5
6
coming to next
that is
michael
and the last name is jackson of course
michael jackson water combination
so
and michael's email is michael at the
rate of simply
dot
n
and the age is 20
and the roll number is 1 6 5
one six five three
four
yeah
now let's execute it
as you can see that all these students
data are in the same format as given
first name last name email age
and roll number
so let us create some department data as
well
and again we will use the row function
so department one equal to road and
inside the bracket we will write
so starting from department
one
as we wrote for the student we will
write for the department department one
equals row then inside the brackets
id
is
zero zero one name
may be math or any subject you want to
take
idea 001 let's take it as math
sorry mith math yeah
then
we will copy this and paste all of them
again
we just have to change the serial number
id and name of the department
that's 3
4
and you can name as it like you want
i will name it in english
then physics
and then chemistry
now suppose you want to look at the
values of sudan 2
so we will use the print command
that will print
in bracket
student
2
this is for a specific
command if you want to local for the
student 3 then you can write print
under the in the bracket student 3
but because it is student 2 the
information is for cassie
so
you can see here the values of row 72
let's create department
now
so
create department with students
instances
you can now see how easy it is to use
python
so with that
we can just write to department with
student one
because we are creating department
it is as same as we created the student
now it's for department so it will be
student with student one
equal to row
and record department is equal to
department one
department
one
then student
is called to
student one
comma student
one comma student two
break it closed
now you just have to copy this and paste
it
and you just have
to change the serial number of the
student and the department only
i will give you an example
like department with student one is
already written so i i wrote department
website into department with student
three
then coming your department with student
four
so we will also change the number here
to
and
then department 4
sorry department 3
and now department 4
and we also have to change the serial
number of students
as you can see i have created some
instances which shows us the students
each department consists of
we can also see details of a particular
student from a department
i will show you that also let's execute
first this
so
now i will show you how it is done so
you just need to execute the command
with print
in bracket department
with student let's assume student three
we are taking the information of student
three
student one
now dot
roll number in bracket
check it closed
so let's secure it
we get the roll number which is 1 3 5 3
six you can see
one three five
here it is one three five three six
now
finally we can create our data frame
let us create an array of sequence of
instances for our data frame
so
let's
create
data frame
coming to code and we will write
department
with students
is equal to
department
with student one in bracket
department
sorry
department student one okay
it's equal to
common department
with
student two
and a department with student three
here department one consists of student
one and two and department two consists
of student three
four department three consists of
student four and five then we need to
create spark context using from
pi spark
dot context
import
spark
context
here spark context
then we will write
from
pi spark
from pi spark dot
sql dot session
import
spark
session
then sc
is equal to
static spark context
sc spark context
dot to
get
or create
and
brackets
then spark
is equal to
spark
session
under bracket river light sc
injector spark context
after this we can create the data frame
so let's execute it first
after the execution we can create the
data frame
we will create data frame df is equal to
spark
because we are creating data frames so
we have to write spark dot
create
data frame
that is df
under break it department with students
department
with
students
so now let's execute this
we can display our data frame
using display function also
so
let's
go to code
20 text
now display
data frame
or
now you can go to code and i display df
and break it
so now as you
see we have the structure of department
which consists of two strings id and
name and the student array which
consists of three strings
first name last name and email and two
integer values which are age and roll
number now as you know how to create a
data frame let us move on to top
youtuber use cases
here we have the data of all the top
youtube channels and it is the csv
format
data frame from csv format
so i'm going to show you how it is done
firstly we will import spark session
from pi spark sql using the same command
i am writing
from pi spark dot
sql
import
spark session
spark session
now let's initiate the spark session to
create a data frame by executing the
following command that is
spark
is equal to
spark
session
dot builder
dot to builder dot
app
name
under the in sorry in the bracket
create
data frame
from csv file create data frame
from
csv file
dot get or create then bracket close
dot
to create bracket code so now as the
spark session is initiated we can use
the spark dot rate command to read the
csv file
and convert it into our data frame which
we have named as yt underscore df
so spark dot read
uh sorry it should be here dot csv
uh in the bracket
path
equals to
youtubers
just have to copy path
and
yeah
so here as you see i have provided a
part to the csv file you can do this by
uploading it on golab let me show you
how it is done
so as it's uploaded now we can right
click on the file and copy the path into
our spark dot rate command
otherwise if you are doing it in the spy
spark shell you can directly copy the
path of the file from the local
directory
oh it's not working i think yeah a small
it will work for sure now
it's working
so
go to text and now
we can
try
out some commands
go to code
this is yt underscore ef dot show get
close
so now as you can see here we have the
country
channel name category to which they
belong username followers likes etc
and many more number column as you can
see only top 20 rows are displayed here
so now what to do if we have to look at
the total number of records in our data
frame
we can use the count function
so
you can see here
it's the total number of records in our
data frame
go to code
we will use the count function
that is
yt
that is youtube underscore
df
dot count bracket close
so here we have total 859 yeah records
or rows in our data frame
now if you want to see the columns you
can see it using the df.show function
as you can see the slider i can move
around to look
at various column but what if you want
to see just the name of column
separately
you will use the same command i am
typing
and there are a lot of columns we can
always use the command function
so it's executed you can see we get to
here we have all the column listed out
now
here we can simply count the number of
columns but for more complex data frame
with lots of columns we can use the
length function on columns
so
here is the
column listed out
we can simply count the number
let's
have the look at the data
and
let's try some complex column
get go to code
type
len because we are use the length
function on columns
len length yt
youtube underscore df.column let's
execute this
so now you can see there are 22 columns
in our data frame now if you want to
know the structure of the data frame
like names of all columns with your data
type then using print
schema
function allows us to go through the
detail structure of our data frame it
specifies each column with its data type
yt underscore df dot primed schema
bracket
clause execute this
you can see the types of columns have
been mentioned here and you can see
nullable as either true or false because
in some data frames maybe some of the
values are supposed to be null moving on
further what if you want to describe a
particular column it can be done using
other function
so let's go on to code i will show you
that
youtube underscore df dot describe
sorry dot describe
and break it
user name
yeah user username
just a second
uh yeah just have to write this
or you can just copy here
and paste it there
username
dot show
and bracket closed
dot
show bracket closed
let's execute it
as you can see the column username has
count is equal to 857 that's 857
which means it has total 857 records
that means it has two null values in it
that is checked
because we already checked total number
of record which is 859.
here mean and standard deviation are
null as we have string values
the minimum value is one million dance
and the maximum is kits diana with the
flower symbol at beginning
so here the minimum and maximum value of
string are set based on alphabetical
order
let's use the describe function on one
more column say it has followers it has
numeric function so let's see
i did the same thing
i just copied and paste the function
again
we just have to
remove username and add follower and now
execute the command
now
also count of total record is 857 and
mean value is approx 49.5 million
something and the standard deviation is
near about 28 million
we just have to copy the command and
paste again
you can see the followers
and we just have to copy that follower
yt underscore df dot describe
followers dot show
we are using describe function here
on one more column say it as followers
it has a numeric values so
let's see
here also count of total records eight
five seven and mean value is approx to
49.5 million something
and the standard deviation is near about
28 million
and the million which is i suppose wrong
compared to the mean says some strategy
video game which is a string
so i think there are some wrong entries
in this particular data set so you can
always check on for mistakes and miss
entries in data frame too
now what if you want all the channel
names and to what categories they belong
to
so we can just select out those
particular column using the select
function
that i am writing
youtube underscore df dot select
going back to the data set
from
we can copy that channel name
just copy and paste here
channel name
yep
so now
category
dot show
we just have to go there category good
copy and paste
that's a shortcut you can use every time
it can save you time also
so category.show
and then we will execute this
and we will see
here you can see the data of two columns
separately so now we can just look out
which channel belong to which category
now suppose we want to filter out some
info from our data frame like we only
want to have channels with followers
over 1 billion
so we can do this using filter function
so
let's go to code
and use filter function
with the yt
underscore
df
dot filter
in brick it
yt underscore df
dot followers
and
just you just have to
write how many
we oh my god 1 billions count is greater
than 1 billion
dot show
so
let's execute this
here we can see all the channels in our
data frame where the followers count is
greater than 1 billion
what if we want to count the number of
channel with 1 billion followers
shown in by above command so instead of
using show function we will use count
with filter
so let's
copy this
and we just have to paste it
here
and
dot count because you are using count
with filter
let's execute the program
so the total number of youtube channels
with more than 1 billion subscriber or
followers we can say are 36.
we can also filter out more than one
condition like this
for that we will use the function
this
again the same function but you just
have to
remove some of the things
that is
from and
writing that again but instead of
filter you have to like write likes
and greater than 1 billion
yt underscore df.filters
yt underscore
df.followers now yttf followers
is one billion dot show
let's go back to the data set and
likes
let's copy this
and paste it there
instead of followers you just have to
like
write like as i said
so just paste it here let's execute the
program
here are all the youtube channels with
followers count is over 1 billion and
the number of likes on those channel is
more than 1 billion
now what if you want to arrange the
record in our data frame in ascending or
descending order
we can use order by function to arrange
our data frame in ascending or
descending order with this function i am
writing
y t underscore df
dot order
by
in break it
just have to write
channel name
dot show
dot show
let's execute this
as you can see data in our data frame is
arranged in ascending order all the
records are arranged in ascending order
for column with string data type
it's arranged alphabetically in
ascending order
now we will try on running some sql
queries on our data frame first
let us create a temporary table using
sql queries
go to code and write to yt
youtube underscore
df dot register
temp
table
in bracket
youtube underscore table
youtube
table
let's execute it
let's see oh i think there's a mistake
let's
recorrect it yt underscore
df dot register okay yeah i forgot to
put underscore youtube underscore table
now let's execute it
now it's running so
now we can use the command let's go to
code
that
is spark
spark
dot sql
in the bracket
select
sorry
select
and
should be from
youtube
underscore
table
spark.sql
select from underscore table
it's running okay
to show all the content of the table we
can also select the particular column
using
the
next command that is show
let's execute it
so
you can see data from a particular
column of the table is fetched out
here you can see every
specific column
on the table so let's go to the code
let's
do a command to see how to run a
particular column
using spark
dot sql
select
user name
user name
from
youtube
underscore
table
and dot show and bracket closed let's
run this program
so yeah it's working
you can see the data
from this column of the table
let's wind up the demo session with this
i hope you understand how to create data
frame with top
10 functions
so with this we have come to the end of
this session on pi spark
i hope you found the session both
interesting and exciting if you have any
questions about any of the topic covered
in this session or if you need the
resources used in this session please
let us know in the comment section below
and our team of experts will be pleased
to respond as soon as possible
thank you until next time this is umbra
from the simply land team signing off
continue to learn and stay safe
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here